Hey how's it go raise me if you go and
search five nights at you're pretty much
guaranteed to find a [ __ ] Emoto 580
copies and that's what we're doing looks
looks pretty good
damn it Thomas oh those that looks all
right this conductor please Thomas God
why Tom
oh god filling the cold fill in the coal
filling the call I think God Thomas is
gone buddy what do you like for me
Thomas I have to refill the girl get out
meow it's not funny
five nights at Meade all right well it's
circle and work it to you temporary job
no better than the original
oh my god this looks so good
five minutes and Froggy's let's students
this is the five nights a fuck-boy
fuckboys one look it's it's mangle and
everything is by me and of the Terek
that's toy no but I need that no but I
need that no but I need it
no but I need a no but I need it fine
Jesus but Oh God it crashed
Oh Oh God this does not look that bad to
be on this what the [ __ ] is that
hello Oh God what's going on
oh god it's ducky not ducky
it's so embarrassing night - all right
well [ __ ] it [ __ ] you ducky
I hear you ducky I know a doctor he is
the son of a [ __ ] he's right [ __ ] ducks
[ __ ] that game five nights at Krusty
Krab the demo waste bench but where the
[ __ ] is spin-spin-spin spam space
belly's missing space bad Spanish memory
you spin speed even squid is that
Squidward that ha ha ha oh my god okay
alright here's my problem with this
anyone who's played this game has played
the original five nights at Freddy's
what's the point really in dragging out
the first nine if nothing is gonna
happen if you like saying yet spongebob
sighs well I don't know this game is
making me feel like I'm oh I made it
then nothing happened oh my god that's
so great oh my god nothing is happening
ah I took y'all and what's the kids -
Cameron hi wow what great if you have
Patrick you're fogging up the lens
alright
Wow some serious paint work went into
this one Wow finite satanic can't wait
to play that don't play ha don't tell me
what to do that will it be great if I I
actually get to play it as well oh my
god
chunky cheese oh my god
Chuck yes are you Oh God so to finish
off this wonderful evening we're gonna
play I'm just gonna go take a [ __ ] and
I'll be right back oh great oh cool
nothing has happened alright that's wow
that was fun I was a lot of fun
alright that was five nights at freddys
copies whatever I think it's fine to
copy games and I think it's kind of
funny like the Thomas one was funny but
if you're gonna make a copy then treat
it as a copy and don't try to replicate
the tension and the way the story is
done because really we don't need
another fineness of Freddie's come on
every three months I mean hey that's my
opinion
what are you best ink on that I want to
thank you guys for watching I hope you
had fun and as always stay off drugs